the oldest human dream what is it maestro hmm the dream the oldest dream
is in greeks oh what it's just the Greeks as I was saying into an old story a
legend Icarus and his father Daedalus find a way out of this labyrinth what if
the minotaur should come and yet you're the one who built this maze of passages
father the labyrinth mm-hmm grab all those chickens wings will fly away be
very careful Icarus doesn't fly too high the Sun will melt the wax holding the
feathers and you'll crash to earth yes father the dream for instance in china forget there was
alibaba and his flying carpet fly leonardo da vinci did more than anyone to realize that he
designed 150 machines do you realize for 500 drawings to find out that human muscles aren't
enough to sustain flight children today we can't appreciate how much imagination he had for his
time now we have to wait till 1783 that's when flight got started in a big way two frenchmen
The Montgolfier brothers made a balloon, and they went off in free flight.
In 1785, another Frenchman, Blanchard, and an American, Jeffreys,
will attempt to fly across the English Channel.
What an adventure.
It's inflated completely. Now we might start.
After you.
You go first, sir.
You, please.
The honor is yours.
Please, sir.
No, after you, after you.
Oh, if you go on like this, your balloon won't go up.
Not at all. It is my fault.
No, no, no. It was mine.
No.
Let's roar, drop, we'll be lighter.
My dear sir, that will not make us lighter, perhaps lightheaded.
Does it out? I should have realized.
The sandwiches are one, whichever is your eye overboard.
This excellent burgundy, if you please.
No question.
Oh, please, you'll be my guest.
Well, if you insist.
Stroh, and the airplane and all that?
Since Leonardo, there's been no shortage of fabulous designs for planes.
If you want, I'll show you some of them.
There were Father Lana's nacelle,
Massarola of Gousse-Mau, machine by Gérard.
There were also flying men, like Barqueville, Le Tour, Damercon, the steam engine.
The middle of the 19th century saw quite a nice collection of largely useless planes.
The Landel, the aerial steamer of Thomas Moy, the f***ing back steam machine.
Flying ship by the great Thomas Edison.
Needless to say, none of these machines ever got off the ground.
But we didn't have long to wait. Flight was around the corner.
A French engineer, Clément Adair, is studying the flight of bats.
Is he dangerous, Mr. Adair?
Bats can do it, so my machine can do it.
Let's go.
At the same time, in Germany,
to Lilienthal and his brother, Gustave...
He's ready. I go.
There's always you, Otto. It's not right, brother.
I want to glide just once.
Come on, just once. Let me go.
Yeah, good, Gustave. You go.
I think I know why it didn't work.
Oh, do you?
The heavier the pilot, the bigger the wing has to be.
That's the answer.
Wings are too small for your weight. Now I'm going to try again.
This is going to be his 2000th flight.
Each time he goes farther.
Yes, the man in flight is a beautiful...
Oh! Oh!
The tragic death of Otto Lilienthal in no way stopped others from testing.
But some of them were funny ones.
Take Sir Hiram Maxim, who had built an enormous machine with a steam engine.
Sir Hiram is mystic on the future of aviation.
In France, Clément Adair carries out another test with unfortunate results.
Jeez, monsieur, I dare that you've made a convincing demonstration that aviation hasn't any future.
At about the same time, near Lake Michigan in the United States,
an old scientist, Octave Chanute, is trying to get his assistant...
Go on!
Airborne.
That didn't work. Well, try another.
First, to get a plane off the ground, the real flyers, hey, were the Wright brothers.
The wings have to be really big, because it's their surface that creates lift, remember?
Yes, but how are we going to steer the thing?
There, look. You'll have to learn how birds do it.
Be careful, Orville.
Don't forget the way Lilienthal ended up.
Right, Wilbur.
Our motto, safety first.
Safety first.
Let's get advice from Chanute.
The expert, that's him.
Sir, who's there?
Sir, my name is Wilbur Wright.
I'm Orville Wright.
We've a bicycle shop.
But now we want to fly.
Uh-uh.
We wondered if you'd give us some help.
The idea of flying instead of pedaling.
Well, sir, this is just how it happened.
It goes back more than 20 years.
It was at Christmas.
Our father, Reverend Milton Wright, gave us a wonderful toy, a sort of helicopter.
Seems flying's all that counts.
Right. And we got really excited by what Lilienthal did.
That's true. We read your book, Progress and Flying Machines.
And so here we are.
All right.
Try to understand the way air keeps this paper clatter up for a time.
Then do your calculations.
But then go on flying, flying, and coming back to Earth
till you understand all that Lilienthal has said.
I have a little gift for you.
Oh.
It's an anemometer for accurately measuring wind speed.
We appreciate it.
Come back and see me whenever you like.
Phil, come help me.
Next week, I think we're going to try a little test.
A steady wind of 15 kilometers an hour.
Conditions are ideal.
Heads or tails?
Heads.
Ha!
Heads, your turn.
Working? Yes, it works!
You're so discouraged.
I think that no man will fly for another thousand years.
And you'd abandon, just give up, all because of one or two bad landings.
Come on, your young fellows, remember what Lillianthal said.
Fly and then fall, and by so doing, learn to fall no more.
The trouble is, we can't figure out a way to steer it.
I want to steer a craft thing for a second.
You need a what?
Sort of rudder.
Seek and ye shall find.
Yes, only the wings can't carry the weight of a man.
Is it so?
And so we have to make them larger.
Or we might change their shape.
He's right.
We have to think about each problem.
We still have to be careful.
At all times, keep an eye on where we're going.
It's working! Now, let's go to lunch.
See? Rounding the leading edge increases the wing's lift.
It's all a question of airflow.
Our wings are flexible with a wire that are linked up to the controls.
So we can bend them.
And at the same time, we'll tilt the tail aileron.
Yes.
This is my assistant. He's very eager to watch your flight.
We're ready to demonstrate. Heads or tails?
I'll take heads.
It's your turn.
Sticky floor for 26 seconds, a distance of nearly 200 meters.
Bravo! Congratulations, boys!
Fluence the wings in flight, and you're using your tail and Iran as a rudder.
Good work.
Now all you need is some sort of engine to propel the craft.
Some sort of engine.
That's right.
And if I'm not mistaken, a Frenchman, Captain Faber, is working on one.
I was forgetting Professor Langley.
Ah, yes. Apparently, he's already carried out some tests.
You know, we're kind of working on one.
...and a gasoline engine.
See, all our calculations are here.
I'm sorry, how did it happen? Tell me, go on.
He crashed just one week ago.
He'd built a sort of platform on the Potomac.
It was a four-place biplane with two propeller gasoline engines.
And right after take-off...
Well, it doesn't mean we're gonna stop.
Heads or tails?
Heads.
This time you're lucky.
Turn now, Orville.
Seventh!
Almost done.
Two hundred and sixty meters, we've done it!
All this passed nearly unnoticed, and it was a great event in history.
Man had truly flown, and for the first time, the Wright brothers were to do even better.
In September 1904, they flew over 1,240 meters, and this time they had full control of the plane.
We did it! We did it!
Too bad not one reporter thought it was important enough to come and witness it for himself and write the story.
Nobody cared about those ridiculous flights.
No, no, Mr. Wright, and his of no interest, the Army doesn't want it.
Machine that flies. The Army doesn't believe it will ever be of any use.
They're a bit of a joke, these Wright brothers, eh, what?
Aimlessly making circles in the air, really, I say.
Playing more than a kilometer, but they must be exaggerating, yes?
Oh, what does it matter, for I tell you, their aviation has no future. You can believe what I say.
Oh, yes, as with all great new inventions, nobody had any trust in it.
But in truth, with the Wright brothers, the age of aviation had really begun once and for all.
In Europe, they're still playing with kites.
La Vanzari managed a few meters.
Sullivan ended up in the water.
Gabriel Voisin did a little better flying a few meters.
And as for Archdeacon's glider, it was, well, powered by a Renault engine, you might say.
Meanwhile, back in the United States...
37 minutes, 37 kilometers! 38 minutes, 38 kilometers!
We're gonna show 'em whether we can fly! Go on!
I don't believe the Wright brothers did everything they claim they did.
What do you think, Farman?
I share exactly your opinion.
Can I imagine how difficult it is to remain in the air for a few minutes?
I may assure you, you're wrong, monsieur. It's a fact, as they claim the rights are flying very well!
If you've any doubt, why don't you organize a little contest?
There's a machine you were flying.
That's it. And I'm gonna win.
Then they'll all have to believe us.
First competition, one complete lap, all right?
Kid, no way.
You see those trees there? Well, they're much too high. I'll hit 'em.
30 seconds. He has beaten your record, Blairio.
Been up for half an hour.
A fantastic flight.
It's a new era in aviation that's opened up.
Mr. Wright, would you mind?
Mrs. Berg would like a ride.
I know she'd so much enjoy it.
It'd be my pleasure, ma'am.
And figure she has.
Smalls are so very...
Skirts, ladies' fashion.
Skirts, nations exclusive.
Perfect variety place.
So, man had learned to fly in just a few years' time.
Then, in the year 1909,
6,000 pounds sterling was a fortune.
It's magnificent.
I know you are going to win it.
This one is superb. Oh, I know that it will win.
Best of luck.
The Antoinette ear is tried and true, Monsieur Latham. You're sure to win.
That's my intention, Mr. Lavoisier.
Sorry, Mr. Wright. Crashed your aeroplane.
It's not your fault. It was a gust of wind.
This machine is damaged.
Bad luck. It is an outstanding machine. And Latham?
Well, he just took off.
Mr. Blair, are you a reporter from the paper?
No, sir. Agent for the customs.
The year of the Great Bioneers would soon be over.
Aviation would become a reality.
The First World War would soon demonstrate how real it was, and progress took its course.
1921, a woman, Adrien Boulogne, flies over the Andes Mountains in South America.
1927, Charles Lindbergh crosses the Atlantic, solo.
First jetliner goes into service, the British Comet.
Now, in our time, flying around is something we take for granted, a matter of routine.
Yes, but when you think about it, just a century ago, we didn't know how to get off the ground.